vous vous avez révélé avoir été trompé
et vous vous en servez dans ce texte
c'était c'était comment de se mettre à
nu sur cette aspect là de votre vie
j'avais un bout dans le spectacle qui
était une histoire sur une fois où je
suis rentré chez ma copine de l'époque
c'était la première fille avec lesquels
je suis resté en couple longtemps et je
suis arrivé elle était j'ai grimpé par
la fenêtre parce que j'avais un doute et
en fait on était en train de se remettre
ensemble parce qu'on s'était séparé
parce que je l'avais trompé et ça
faisait un moment qu'on se revoyait et
là je la chope dans le lit avec avec
quelqu'un et je racontais ça avant dans
le spectacle et j'ai un lieu parce que
c'était c'était un petit peu long mais
c'est vrai que dans le spectacle c'est
un de c'est
une des choses que j'ai un peu de du mal
à assumer que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
assumer sur scène parce que ce qui
fonctionne sur scène au-delà de l'effet
comique de la surprise c'est aussi
l'empathie qu'on peut avoir avec les
gens et en fait ça nous enlève toutes
tout lien avec les gens quand on dit bah
oui moi j'ai été quelqu'un infidèle
pendant longtemps
souvent souvent se déconnecte du public
d'une grosse partie du public et donc ça
c'était un truc dur à assumer c'est un
sujet dur à à
expliquer et à justifier mais je pense
que la fidélité c'est une certaine
vision de de l'amour qui ne correspond
pas à tout le monde après c'est un choix
c'est une preuve
d'amour qu'on peut donner à quelqu'un
mais je pense pas que ce soit quelque
chose de il y a des couples qui ne sont
pas exclusifs et qui le vivent plutôt
bien je crois on est où c'est à
Saint-Vincent au Cap Vert
dont vos parents sont issus
vous étiez portugais à la naissance vous
et pas français faut pas dire ça
pourquoi faut pas le dire c'est un truc
c'est marrant c'est un truc mais je
crois que je le raconte dans mon
spectacle précédent il me semble
parce que j'ai appris très tard moi
j'étais
j'ai appris je passe dehors 8 9 ans et
je me rappelle que j'étais hyper déçu je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai toujours eu cette
fierté d'être français et
c'est vrai que quand ma mère elle m'a
appris que ah non mais quand tu es née
tu étais portugais au départ et ensuite
tu as été naturalisé ça m'a fait quelque
chose parce qu'en fait petit on se
moquait beaucoup de de mes cousins qui
eux avaient la nationalité portugais
portugaise porno parce que j'ai deux
cousins qui ont lancé portugaise encore
aujourd'hui et nous on s'était des
blagues qu'on se faisait entre nous et
c'est vrai qu'au départ j'étais déçu
aujourd'hui c'est un bagage culturel
dont je suis évidemment extrêmement fier
aussi de pouvoir parler portugais de
parler le créole
d'être même je me rends compte que cette
vue là avec laquelle j'ai pas du tout
grandi
viens me voir très facilement c'est quoi
cette main qui dissimule une partie de
votre visage on est en 2010 c'était il y
a 12 ans
comme quoi on fait bien on demande qu'à
en rire au début à la télé
contrasté ses débuts peut-être avec
un jambon Guigui
que les anges que j'ai et
le bon goût de cette veste je suis
vraiment surprises
quand on voit des années avant mais
c'est quoi ce et là le c'est déjà un
style un fichier
pendentif et tout mais elle est
contrastée cette expérience en fait
c'est le problème entre guillemets de ce
genre d'émission c'est que il y a des
gens comme moi à l'époque qui arrivent
et qui font leur première scène
en tout cas depuis quelques semaines
quoi je monte je crois que je monte au
chargement de communic club toutes les
lesges salut Françoise d'Aldi qui est
aurélienvic je monte toutes les semaines
une fois par semaine et ça ça doit faire
quelques mois que je fais de la scène
comme ça sur Paris dans cette forme là
parce que moi j'ai commencé plutôt mais
en fait il y a des gens donc qui sont
vraiment très verts comme moi dans
l'émission et il y a d'autres personnes
comme
Olivier de Benoît Jérémy Ferrari qui
viennent et qui ont des années de scènes
derrière eux qui jouent déjà leur
spectacle qui sont déjà pour certains
produits et en fait dans cette émission
on est mis au même niveau et c'est pas
expliqué et c'est pas et du coup on est
jugé de la même façon alors qu'on ne
peut pas être jugé de la même façon et
du coup c'était évidemment une erreur je
conseillerais à personne qui commence
l'humour d'aller dans ce genre
d'émission c'est vraiment une émission
pour des humoristes qui font ce travail
là et qui ont besoin d'un tremplin faut
pas du tout faire ça quand on commence
l'humour il faut faire des petites
scènes encore encore pendant des années
deux trois quatre cinq ans et prendre le
temps c'est comme du du ce qu'on dit du
bon vin quand il faut vraiment prendre
il faut vraiment prendre le temps parce
que les années de scène c'est comme les
années de maturité dans la vie et ont on
n'a pas envie de de percer à 5 ans c'est
votre premier passage au Jamel Comedy 2e
passage deuxième passage au Jamel Comedy
Club donc ce fameux sketch du legging on
est dans 2014 là qu'est-ce qui se passe
en vous
ouais non il y a rien de plus stressant
que que ça parce que c'est un moment
très le stand up il y a un truc vraiment
de naturel de laisser aller un truc très
organique et là c'est vraiment une
émission de télé donc c'est filmé télé
on n'a pas la sensation d'une scène elle
est grosse caméra c'est un public qui
est chauffé c'est très différent donc il
y a là c'est vraiment le l'aboutissement
de plusieurs mois de de travail on sait
qu'on va avoir ce à l'époque le Jamel
Comedy Club c'est vraiment ce truc que
tout le monde veut faire et on sait les
conséquences que ça peut avoir donc
c'était un énorme enjeu pour moi et
c'est l'équivalent de d'un match de
Ligue des Champions quoi c'est c'est
vraiment on a chaque blague qui passe
c'est comme c'est vraiment comme une
discipline ouais c'est comme le un oral
du bac et dans la foulée est-ce que vous
pourriez me dire aussi pourquoi vous
avez je sais pas une envie de modifier
ce sketch vous l'auriez pas écrit de la
même manière quelques années plus tard
ce sketch aujourd'hui
il y a évidemment plein de choses que je
dirais pas là il y a une partie il y a
une boule du sketch je parle après sur
Christiane Taubira je leur ai dit
différemment et là pareil c'est là c'est
vraiment sur un fil qui est déjà sur un
fil à l'époque mais je pense que c'est
comme plein de choses il y a des choses
en télé qui pourraient plus passer
aujourd'hui
sur le fond comme comme sur la façon de
le faire
là c'est un peu limite on est en 2019
31e cérémonie des Molières et un sketch
quick là encore avec cette phrase
mythique qui tape au sein de la grande
famille du théâtre salut les blancs
c'est évidemment une forme d'insolence
mais c'est aussi
j'allais dire une verbalisation qui fait
du bien
je sais pas si tout le monde rit de la
même chose mais ouais
mais c'est probablement l'un des trucs
dont je suis le plus fier dans ma
carrière
ça m'a un peu été gâché d'ailleurs parce
que il y a il y avait un humoriste je
sais pas si je puis dire moi si vous
avez des vidéos sur YouTube et tout qui
m'avait
accusé de lui avoir pris ça alors que je
parce qu'il avait fait un tweet des
années avant et tout alors que je peux
pas sur Twitter mais ça m'invitait un
bain peu gâché par par cette histoire là
mais toutes les blagues derrière aussi
me j'en suis très très fier j'avais
écrit ça à l'époque avec Thomas disait
et je l'avais testé dans un une scène
qui s'appelait le
Barbès et après j'ai dit à Thomas visuel
brillant humoriste en passant
si j'essayais de le dire à la cérémonie
et alors évidemment il y a des sourires
et puis il y a des sourires forcés vous
n'êtes pas dupe de ça évidemment farine
mais c'était essentiel de pointer cette
absence de diversité particulièrement
peut-être au théâtre c'était important
de le pointer c'était important de le
dire
sous cette forme là
en réalité c'est un peu facile à dire
parce qu'on arrive dans une période
c'est pas très très loin de Black Light
Merr je crois c'est
sympa avant mais on est dans une période
où c'est un truc qui est beaucoup plus
facile à dire et beaucoup on va avoir
beaucoup plus de gens qui vont y adhérer
après est-ce que c'est nécessaire je
sais pas
encore aujourd'hui moi j'aime bien faire
ce genre de blague c'est un humour que
qui m'intéresse c'est pour ça là-bas il
y avait Bob Marley Bob Marley c'est
brillant musicalement mais aussi dans le
propos c'est fort après moi je sais pas
si ça a de l'impact ça je suis pas j'y
crois pas trop à ça mais je trouve ça
drôle votre maman a eu peur pour vous
ouais ouais c'est vrai ah ouais c'est
vrai elle vous a demandé de faire gaffe
de pas finir comme Dieudonné
mais c'est une peur de maman quoi
c'était quoi c'était la peur de la
tentation de la bascule de sa part non
c'est la peur de mal être compris c'est
la peur que on puisse massimiler à autre
chose et puis des fois aussi je pense
que c'est ce qui arrive à ce qui arrive
à Dieudonné des fois dans juste par
principe de contradiction
et ben on va s'enfoncer dans quelque
chose
par en tête moi
donc
ouais c'est des peurs de maman